this is a level 158 pepper panic saga
walkthrough
i'm going to play the level it's a tough
level it's actually
probably the toughest in episode 11 and
the one that gave
players the most problems
it's difficult because the statues are
off on the
in the corners and um
there are six colors of peppers on the
board so it's very hard to make matches
and get things
to grow
in the beginning
you don't want to get rid of the cages
so in the beginning you just kind of
want to make a look around see what
color
is best or
what the best colors are
yellow looks like it's the best and
purple looks like it's the worst because
there's no purple peppers trapped in the
cages so
see we can do
in the beginning i'm just going to be
growing peppers i'm going to match this
one first because then set up the next
match of yellow
and i got lucky and got an extra
an extra yellow out of the deal
trying to get the reds in a shape so i
can make an l
even though there's only one trapped red
one it's still
a good thing to
grow that rather than the purple
uh at times you're gonna have to grow
the purple to get them out of the way so
that's just what happens when there's
this many colors sitting around
you just want to
you know check the board to make sure
that you're not missing out on a big
match um
the
you it's nice to clear the ice so if we
do match the purples that'll be fine
it just won't lead us anywhere in the
long run
like i mentioned the yellow looks to be
the best color so
we might even go out of our way a little
bit to match that
i went ahead and waited one move there
because i wanted to see if
i could get some other things to happen
below
not a great result but uh we have this
one down to one we lost all of our cages
there
and um
we got one hit on both of the bottom
statues so it's not bad
um
let's try to see
now this is a good match because uh
it'll explode
and we'll get a chain reaction and
that'll take out that one and hopefully
get that one also
of course it moves
right beforehand
um but we're in a pretty good spot here
if we can keep that one up there for a
second then
we have 17 moves
and uh we need four hits total
i always look to the bottom of the board
first but in this case there's really
not a lot
that we can do down there i'm gonna
match this one and yeah so i can
get a chain reaction started with the
orange
okay so now we have
the two hardest statues on the board to
hit
this is why you want to preserve your
cages if you can
it's not the end of the world but um
this is going to be substantially harder
than if
you know we had some cages
i'm going to go ahead and match the
oranges and you know start a cascade to
see what happens
we got one
so that's good
um
whenever you have one statue at the top
you always want to
try to set up a shock wave obviously you
can see here that this line goes all the
way across and there's definitely no
way to set one up
so
you can't really count on these colors
to be here by the time that you
actually get you know we don't have any
grown peppers really at all so
you know just one here or there so you
can't really
when you're matching you're going to
lose these ones that are sitting by here
anyway so i would just look to grow the
color the fastest which is
you know i made that l match that grew
the green
and it also grew this yellow one here
and um
that's really
with this many colors you really can't
plan all that much better than that um
i'm going to clear this row right here
because it's going to grow these blue
ones and see where things fall into
place
i'm going to grow the blue again
i'd like to be able to grow the yellow
be on this side of the board because
then i could
i could probably get this one to explode
but
let's see what happens when we grow this
one
all right that'll do it so that's the
way you have to think about it you just
want to uh
try to keep them in the cages as long as
you can
and when when you can't you just have to
you know adjust your thinking based on
what's available
um hope this will help you out if you're
stuck on the level
it's difficult but it's definitely
beatable
i think this was my third try so
just hang in there and follow the tips
in our full guide
make sure you like us on facebook and if
you have any questions leave a comment
and we'll get back to you right away
thanks